meghan markle and prince harry drop an
extra sweet holiday surprise on thursday
by sharing their family's christmas card
which just so happens to include the
first photo they publicly shared of
daughter lilibit diana since her birth
in june the sussex family went for a
casual look in the sweet snapshot with
harry megan and their two-year-old son
archie rocking jeans
the duke even has a rip at the knee
meanwhile megan holds up their baby girl
who was grinning down at her family
now that's a photo debut
pretty special as far as holiday plans
for harry meg and their kiddos royal
expert katie nichol gave e.t her
thoughts earlier this year i think the
idea of christmases together is probably
not likely to happen this year of course
the covered pandemic does mean that
international travel is more challenging
i do know that it was harry's plan to
come back and spend time in england
particularly during and the summer the
holiday period but i think we can be
certain that harry and megan will be
coming back to britain i think the
platinum jubilee celebrations in june
2022 are a likely opportunity for them
to come over to be a part of the
official celebrations of the queen's
70th year
i
still view her more as the queen than my
grandmother it gets hammered into not
hammered into you but you you have this
huge amount of respect for for your boss
and i always view her as my boss
as for the rest of the royal family a
palace source tells et prince charles
and camilla
will be joining her majesty for
christmas at windsor et has also learned
prince edward and sophie their children
and prince andrew's family who live near
windsor castle are expected to see the
queen during the christmas holiday
prince william and kate middleton had
been scheduled to stay at anmer hall
located on the sandringham estate with
their kids prince george princess
charlotte and louie a source close to
the royal family also told et details
are still being worked out how the move
to windsor castle will adjust christmas
plans will and kate also shared their
own family's 2021 christmas card earlier
this month but back to the duke and
duchess of sussex's card let's talk
about this for a second the pick was
snapped by photographer alexey
lubimerski who also took the couple's
engagement and wedding photos the fan
posed for the kodak moment over the
summer at their home in santa barbara
california and in case you missed it the
christmas card reads this year 2021 we
welcomed our daughter lillabet to the
world archie made us a mama and a papa
and lily made us a family as we look
forward to 2022 we have made donations
on your behalf to several organizations
that honor and protect families from
those being relocated from afghanistan
to american families in need of paid
parental leave the card ends with this
note wishing you a happy holiday season
and prosperous new year from our family
to yours as ever harry megan archie and
lily
[Music]